Let's assume for now that the running time of this algorithm is 2n+a+1,
so even for this simple algorithm, the running time depends on both the size of the inputs
to the length of the string and the structure of the input, which in this case
is the number of times the letter a occurs.
And this is of course very problematic because on the one hand when we get
more complicated algorithms, the formula here will get very, very complicated.
And the second thing is that most of the time we don't even know what kinds of strings
the algorithm will encounter, so we cannot get rid of this variable without making any assumptions.
We want to avoid these complications and there's actually
three different ways you could do that.
The first one would be to have a very optimistic view and state the running time
for the best possible input that this algorithm could receive.
Basically saying this is the minimum running time of the algorithm
and state that as its overall running time.
You could, of course, also take the opposite view and say--we're going to state the running time
as a worst-case view, so we're going to be very pessimistic almost like there was an adversary
who is giving us the worst possible inputs and then state that as the running time.
And then finally we can take an in between view and say--well, the usual input for the algorithm
is not going to be your best case.
It's also not going to be the worst case, so let's state some kind of average.